afternoon everybody thank you for coming
here this afternoon to this press
conference my name is superintendent
Richard Harris I'm going to read to you
a short statement and I'll hand you over
to my colleague from the fire service
who will also read a short statements
and then we will take some questions
from yourselves
so first and foremost on behalf of
everybody in the community and on behalf
of Westminster police I would like to
pass on our deepest sympathies at this
time
the tragic circumstances yesterday
afternoon
so close to Christmas time and our
sympathies with the families who have
lost loved ones in this incident I'd
also like to say that we are supporting
the families we have specialist trained
officers who are linking in with the
families at this time to offer them as
much support as we possibly can
we've also linked in with the local
schools which children attended within
this area and the schools are also
offering support to any pupils who may
wish to receive support at this awful
time
our officers were quick to respond at
the scene yesterday afternoon and having
worked very closely with our colleagues
from other Emergency Services went into
the lake itself to help rescue the
children and to try and assist them as
quickly as we possibly could
we've worked very closely with our
colleagues in westman's fire service and
also in westman's Ambulance Service and
this has been a real joint effort
it is incredibly sad that we do not have
any better news for you today
regarding yesterday afternoon's incident
that's all I have to say at this moment
in time I'm going to pass over to to my
colleague now from the fire service and
then we'll we'll be open to take any
questions
thank you Richard
we are deeply saddened by the death of
three boys who were rescued by our
firefighters yesterday here at the lake
in solihull
the boy's deaths are a tragedy beyond
words
and the thoughts
and heartfelt sympathies of everyone
here at westminton's fire service are
with their families friends and The
Wider communities at this distressing
time
yesterday's incident is a stark reminder
to us all of the dangers of Open Water
especially during the winter months
frozen lakes ponds canals and reservoirs
can look picturesque but they can be
lethal and there are no greater warnings
of this than yesterday's tragic events
we would ask parents and carers to
remind their children of the dangers of
ice
and why they must keep off it please
help us to avoid this from happening
again
we will continue to work closely with
our emergency service colleagues and
provide any support that we can at the
scene
again we extend our heartfelt sympathies
to everyone who has been affected by the
boy's deaths
thank you
from Sky News can you just give us some
information regarding the ongoing work
here at the lake and whether or not
there are further people unaccounted for
so yes yesterday evening we had a number
of different reports suggesting numbers
of young people that may have been on
the lake
those reports don't match the children
that were rescued from the lake
yesterday however we have to be 100
certain that there is no one else and
possibly in the water at this time we
it's important to stress though that
we've had no contact from anybody
suggesting that there's anybody else
missing but until we're a hundred
percent certain we will be carrying on
searches throughout the course of today
and how long do you expect to be here
with foreign
as long as it takes we've got specialist
Crews and we've got specialist equipment
that's in the water that allows us to
see what's in the water so we'll be here
for as long as it takes until we're
absolutely certain there is no one left
in time at the family's request we're
not going to go into those details we're
working very closely with the family and
supporting them as you can imagine that
we are when the family are ready to
release those details then we will let
you know you need to keep your friends
and family are they from the same family
I'm not going to be drawn on that one at
this moment in time thank you
the the other boy at the moment he's
still very poorly and will keep you
advised on on his condition as uh as it
becomes clear to ourselves
yes
I've been in touch with with the local
schools and again at the family's
request we're not going to go into too
much detail around uh names or the
actual schools that the children went to
have you spoken specifically Anthony's
okay
I'm not going to make a comment on that
one at this time I'm sure you'll
understand the family's wishes
again at this moment in time the
families have asked us not to release
any further details than what I'm able
to provide you this morning I'm afraid
as soon as the families are are happy
we'll we'll be able to release you some
more information on that it's probably a
stupid question but how are the family
as you can imagine uh absolutely
devastated
um
also at this time of year it's it's on
the run-up to Christmas
um so close to the to the event itself
um also adds to that tragedy but as you
can imagine the families are absolutely
devastated which is why we're we're
doing our very best to support the
families and obviously we're we're
abiding by their requests at the moment
as to how much information that the
families want us to to make available to
to the media so we're doing everything
we possibly can to support them and I'm
sure you'll understand that we are led
by the family's wishes as to how much
information that we can say at the
moment
as well
just how grateful those people so
um from my understanding is yes police
officers did go into into the water they
were joined by other members of the
other Emergency Services some of the
officers went in uh Waist Deep
one of my officers was trying to punch
through the ice to to actually rescue
the the children themselves that officer
as a result of that had some mild
hypothermia yesterday I'm pleased to say
that he's now been released from
hospital and he's absolutely fine in
relation to and I'm sure again you'll
understand we're still trying to work
through all the details that that came
into us last night we've got quite a few
witnesses that we need to we need to
speak to and we're currently still
working through that at the moment I'd
just like to take this opportunity just
really to make an appeal that if anybody
has any information
or saw any events that took place
yesterday afternoon leading up to this
tragic incident
if they could go on to our Westwinds
Police website there are contact details
on there on how to get in touch with us
and then officers will be in touch in
due course but we're still trying to
piece together exactly what happened
leading not to uh yesterday afternoon's
events
so as I say yesterday's incident is
tragic and everybody within the fire
service Community will feel that
they did everything they could under the
circumstances to get into the water to
rescue the four boys and to bring them
out to the ambulance Series so that they
could receive treatment but you will
appreciate they are you know deeply
disappointed by the news that we've been
told today
the children were in the water
at this moment of time I don't have the
answer to that question the officers and
other Emergency Services arrived as as
quickly as we were informed
um at that time the the call which came
into US was at 2 34 PM so it was in
minutes with the report coming in that
we arrived at the scene but the exact
time of the the children were exposing
the water I don't have that information
at this time
once you're right on the scenes you then
know how how long it took to actually
locate them and get them out
so for the fire service we arrived on
the scene quickly alongside our
colleagues in the police and ambulance
service it is quite a large lake and it
did take some time in order to identify
exactly where their point of entry was
but as soon as that was established
firefighters entered the water alongside
colleagues and members of the public in
order to try and rescue them as quickly
as possible
if the officers went straight in yes we
they were without regard to their own
safety they they entered the water in
just their normal trousers and shoes
which is what I'm wearing today so they
went in dressed as time
and a very similar picture for the fire
service our initial Crews that arrived
on scene made their way straight into
the water in their normal firefighting
kit and then when the specialist water
rescue teams came along they entered the
water with with different levels of PPE
there are no injuries to Firefighters
that I've been made aware of
if you have any more information on the
events of the public who apparently
I don't at this time will as those
details come through we'll we'll let you
know but at this moment it's on sorry I
don't have that only survived the first
one to be pulled out of the league
um not again at the families requested
I'm not going to go into actual details
around the children themselves and the
condition but as soon as the family are
happy for us to release that we'll we'll
let you know
shot is he being treated affirming of
children
I'm not and again as the family's
request we're not going to divorge which
hospitals the children went to
again the the family's request I'm not
going to release any further information
around that until they're happy for us
to to release any further details
there's no suggestion of any criminal
investigation
at the moment we from a policing
perspective we our main concern is to
support the families at this tragic time
we're not currently looking at any any
criminal investigation
foreign